[Music]
our bodies are designed for scarcity for
not enough and so we fill our homes up
with stuff and we're scanning all the
time and it's never enough and we get
more stuff and more stuff and instead of
our tribal Natures instead of looking
around saying we're good now we have
these little devices and we're not
competing with the Joneses anymore we're
competing with everyone on planet Earth
we can't fit all of our stuff in our
2,000 3,000 4,000 ft homes so we have to
rent other air condition places to put
our stuff into but we look around and
we're
suffocating under stuff under clutter
Freedom looks like asking yourself do I
have this shelf of books because I'm
going to read them or do I have this
shelf of books because I need to
announce to the world whoever comes into
my home look how smart I am look at what
I read one time and if you're looking
for inanimate objects to give you your
identity you're not free